[music]
[singing]
>> There is a special request from my side
that
during the full Dawah training program
please don't ask certain questions
which will take the Dawah training
program
to a different
tangent.
For example
if you ask what are views about
the Islamic State of Iraq and Syria.
That requires us to discuss.
This is a Dawah training program.
Talk about Dawah.
It may be indirectly related. I'm aware
of it.
If you want we can discuss maybe for
half an hour, have a session
separate, but don't keep on adding
everywhere. Any topic comes up you ask
on this.
Yes, you can ask me
on actions.
Is it right to kill innocent human
being? That I'll reply.
And if we answer
we dies get
taken into a different field and they
want to trap us.
We don't want this training program
to be
in a different angle all together.
How to reply them is a different
technique.
Which you might have seen some of my
tapes.
But let's not
any of the sessions ever in all these 33
days discuss about particular
people especially about this.
And
we unfortunately
we promote such things. And if those who
have been on my Facebook. How many of
you go to my Facebook regularly?
1 2 Masha Allah. 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 13 14 Masha Allah. 14 out of 19.
Alhamdulillah, more than 70%.
Did anyone read my post
in the beginning of this year?
It happened to be coincidental
exactly in the start of this year.
1:00 a.m. 1st January somewhere close to
1:00 a.m.
it was a post on the Facebook
that
most of the Muslims
unintentionally
promote the anti-Islamic forces.
Most of our Muslims
unintentionally promote
the anti-Islamic forces.
For example
if I say
that I am the president of USA.
Will you call me Mr. President?
Or will you call me the president of
USA? And the answer is no.
The people or the media
will either call me a liar or they'll
call me a lunatic.
So when the terrorists
who kill innocent people
in the name of Islam
call themselves
Islamic State of Iraq and Syria
why do we
agree
and call them with that name?
Why do we agree that they ISIS? Why do
we agree that they are the Islamic State
of Iraq and Syria? We should in fact say
that they are anti-Islamic State of Iraq
and Syria.
AISS, not ISIS.
So if I tell
in my innocence
ignorantly
that ISIS killed
10 Europeans who are innocent. That
means I'm telling that Islamic State of
Iraq and Syria killed 10 innocent
people. That means I am promoting
and I'm agreeing that Islam allows the
killing of 10 innocent people.
In fact
I should say the anti-Islamic forces
of Iraq and Syria killed 10 innocent
people.
And unfortunately not only the Western
media
not only the general media, even the
Muslim media repeats it.
In no way
does Islam promote terrorism.
In no way does Islam allow the killing
of innocent human beings.
Allah clearly says in Surah Ma'idah
chapter 5 verse number 32 that if anyone
kills any innocent human being whether
Muslim or non-Muslim unless for murder
or for spreading corruption in the land,
it is as though he has killed the whole
of humanity. And if anyone saves any
innocent human being, it is as though he
has saved the whole of humanity. If
anyone kills any innocent human being,
it is as though you have killed the
whole of humanity.
So when Islam is so clear
and unfortunately most of the dies also
repeat that.
So when I say
I'm very careful.
And again
I make it very clear
that we should not unintentionally
and ignorantly
promote the anti-Islamic forces. So
coming back to the point that as far as
this 33 days Dawah training program is
concerned
please do not
hijack the training program to a
different level.
Let's talk about Dawah calling people to
Islam.
And we as dies should know let not
people take you away
on a tangent
so that you lose your focus. So during
the training program see to it that ask
questions on the topic of this session.
And see to it that even if it's a
question related to it don't get names
or ask questions on
such things which will take the training
to a different angle all together.
Hope that is clear.
Clear?
Masha Allah.
Point number 17.
Every day
daily post training evaluation sheet
will be given to you before the start of
the first session.
This sheet
should be filled by you at the end of
each session
and shall be completed and handed over
after the last session before you leave
the auditorium.
Every day
there'll be a post evaluation sheet
given to you.
Normally it's given at the beginning of
the first session. Did you receive it
today?
Yes, the reason you didn't receive
because we didn't want people coming
with papers inside. So inshallah at the
end of the first session you'll get it.
There's a post evaluation sheet
in which you have to give
your rating and comments on each
session.
How was the session? Was it fruitful?
Was it excellent? Very good, good, fair.
The pros, the cons.
And it's preferable you write
immediately after the session.
And before you leave
the auditorium
that is the last session of the day,
hand it over
to the faculty inshallah.
Point number 18.
Every day homework would be given.
It's compulsory that all the
participants should complete the
homework.
Point number 19. Every day each
participant would be evaluated. The
major criteria for evaluation would be
A.
Techniques of public speaking. B.
Structure and content of Islamic talks.
C.
Public lecture. D. Techniques of
handling the question answer session.
E.
The debating skills.
F. Names with meanings of the 114 Surahs
of the Quran.
G. Memorization of the Quranic verses
with translation helpful for Dawah. H.
Memorization of the verses
of the Bible and Hindu scriptures which
are helpful for Dawah.
I.
The surprise.
J.
The question asked. Even the questions
you ask
there will be a note made
and
we'd like to know
that depending on the question asked the
instructor
can evaluate the passion
of
the participant
the intelligence level of the
participant.
So whenever
you have to evaluate
the questions asked
in a classroom to a teacher or by a
participant in a workshop or in a
training program is a good way of
measuring
the level of the participant.
His interest, his intelligence, his
knowledge
his criteria
to judge.
Has he understood the subject?
So based on the question I can come to
know okay this person is just a
beginner. Okay, he's in the middle. He's
in the high level. He's asking PhD
questions.
Some people just ask PhD questions they
don't know in between.
So then he gets caught. He's asking
something high level. He doesn't know
what is in the second standard, third
standard, 10th standard. He's asking a
question of post graduation.
That means he's trying to think he's too
smart.
And he's exposed.
So what questions asked
is a good way of measuring
the intelligence,
the passion,
and the commitment of the questioner.
So, everything
that's mentioned here, there'll be an
evaluation which will help us
in giving marks
to the participants.
Point number 20.
At the end of the international Dawah
training program,
a certificate of participation will be
given to only those participants who
attend all the 33 days
of the training program without missing
a single session
or a part of a session.
If any participant misses
even few minutes
of any of the sessions, he will not be
given the certificate of participation.
It's a very important point.
The attendance is compulsory
and the completion certificate or
certificate of participation will only
be given to those participants who
attend all the 33 days,
all the sessions of the days,
not missing even few minutes.
For example,
one candidate from Saudi Arabia,
the visa was delayed.
It wasn't for his fault.
He said, "Inshallah, I'll try and come
in the next 2 days."
Even if I allow him to come,
because he's coming late, he will not
get the certificate of participation.
It wasn't his fault.
But,
the rule is there, you have to follow
the rule.
Yes,
I told him
that
while the training program goes on, the
main training starts from the third day.
Normally, it's on the second day,
but I relaxed the full program, and this
program I have relaxed it much more than
before.
The main thing starts on the second day.
This time I've put something in between
so that a person come one day earlier,
he relaxes. But, I told him that if he
lands even day after tomorrow, he has to
see 8 hours of both the days.
So, if he catches up with it,
then he can attend the third day. So, if
Monday is a holiday, if he reaches it
maybe on
Sunday night
or Monday morning, if he makes it,
inshallah, he will have to spend the
full Monday
watching the 16 hours
of the training to attend the
third day of the training.
So, attendance is compulsory.
>> [music]
[music]
[chanting]